cuáles de los siguientes triángulos son
similares al triángulo abc el triángulo
a abc es este que nos indican aquí y nos
da nuestras opciones
bueno aquí como pueden ver yo ya vi cuál
es la respuesta correcta pero lo que
vamos a hacer es analizar cada una de
estas opciones para verificar es porque
esta es la respuesta correcta
vamos a recordar un poco qué son los
triángulos similares
recordemos que dos triángulos van a ser
similares siempre y cuando todos sus
ángulos internos sean iguales vamos a
dibujar por ejemplo este triángulo así y
ahora voy a dejar otro con diferentes
dimensiones
más o menos así entonces un trémolo va a
ser similar a otro cuando tenemos que
sus ángulos internos correspondientes
son congruentes o son iguales este
ángulo de aquí es igual a este de aquí
este ángulo de acá va a ser igual al
ángulo que está aquí
y este ángulo de aquí arriba va a ser
igual a el ángulo que se encuentra aquí
al correspondiente en el orden en el que
aparecen los generales los triángulos
cuando demostramos que son similares es
que podemos una vez que mostramos que lo
son podemos decir que la proporción
entre sus lados va a ser la misma por
ejemplo la proporción en este lado de
aquí que le voy a poner a con respecto a
este lado de acá que le voy a llamar d
esta proporción de entre b
/ b va a ser la misma proporción que si
yo tomo este lado correspondiente que le
voy a llamar c y este otro lado de aquí
abajo correspondiente a este otro que lo
voy a llamar d así que esta proporción
va a ser igual a la del lado c con
respecto al lado de bueno que tiene que
ver esto con el que tengamos aquí una
meta bueno la pendiente de esta recta va
a ser constante el cambio en x va a ser
perfectamente horizontal y el cambio en
hacer perfectamente vertical de manera
que se forma un triángulo rectángulo
aquí cualquier triángulo rectángulo que
se construya usando dos puntos que estén
sobre esta recta serán similares entre
sí pues la proporción del cambio en y
con respecto al cambio en x era la misma
bueno ahora vamos a resolver lo que nos
piden acá nos dicen si este triángulo a
veces que está aquí marcado vamos a
compararlo con la que se forma por
efe vamos a ponerlo de un color
diferente el triángulo formado por ve
por él
y por efe este triángulo formado aquí
bueno vemos que aquí esta inclinación de
la hipotenusa es diferente no es
paralela a la de nuestra recta aquí y
aunque éste forma un ángulo recto pues
podemos ver de entrada que las
proporciones no son correctas
estos triángulos no son similares así
que esta primera opción no lo es ya sé
ya sabemos que es la última pero de
todas maneras vamos a analizar cada uno
de ellos
ahora el triángulo formado por b de g
usemos otro color el triángulo formado
por b
d
este triángulo de acá bueno este también
es todavía más obvio que no es similar
ya que esta inclinación de la hipotenusa
es muy diferente a la de nuestra línea
recta que es la que forma la hipotenusa
del triángulo que estamos comparando
entonces bueno esta opción pues
definitivamente tampoco lo es ahora nos
preguntan el triángulo formado por el fg
efe
este triángulo de acá
estaban bastante más chiquito pero igual
estamos viendo que no es similar al
triángulo que tenemos acá esta forma es
muy diferente a la que tiene la forma de
este triángulo entonces esta opción
tampoco es la tachamos y bueno la que ya
sabemos que si es pero vamos a ver por
qué si es esta opción la buena a g
y de a bueno de aquí de entrada tanto de
como dan son dos puntos que están sobre
esta misma recta y quedamos bueno aquí
vemos que forman ángulos rectos este
segmento de g es completamente
horizontal y el segmento ag es
completamente vertical forman un ángulo
recto es un triángulo rectángulo y ya
habíamos quedado que todos los
triángulos rectángulos que sean formados
por dos puntos sobre esta recta van a
ser similares entre sí así que este a
deje que expuse en rojo es similar al
original que de hecho aquí se alcanza a
ver comparte estos dos lados nada más
tiene este otro segmento que es paralelo
al de aquí abajo entonces todo esto
confirma que efectivamente este es
triángulo similar al que nos dan aquí